[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man there was a lot to recap
bucks close out the nets hawks close out
the sixers
jazz ball out suns beat the clippers no
nba coming up tonight jon ron wins
the u.s open that's a busy weekend
reggie miller will be on the call for
the eastern conference finals on tnt
between the hawks
and the bucks beginning wednesday at 8
30 eastern
yeah i'm sure you predicted that didn't
you reg hawks versus the bucks
we went to we went to vegas didn't we
put no
put money down on the on the bucks and
the hawks
well i i had i
i remember you and i distinctly having
that conversation
hey reg let's go put down our money on
the milwaukee bucks
and the atlanta hawks to be in the
eastern conference finals
wow all right before we get to the
winning teams let me start with the
losing teams
seems they're more interesting here let
me start with philadelphia i brought
this up to you last year i think i've
brought this up to you
in the last two years with ben simmons
um what would you do with ben simmons if
you're philadelphia you want to keep him
so what do you do i i think you
go out to a hardware store
and you buy all the locks possible
you put them in a gym and you padlock
the door shut
i think look but the storm is bad reg i
i
he's going to take a beating this off
season and a little bit rightfully so
it's not so much that he wasn't shooting
he wasn't
aggressive at all and i don't mind him
missing jump shots or whatever but put
pressure
on the defense he wasn't putting any
pressure
on atlanta whatsoever and at 6 10
in that frame all i got to do is put him
in the mid post and let him get a couple
crab dribbles until he gets into the
paint collapse the defense
that's being aggressive it's not always
taking shots people assume
that when i say tell people to be
aggressive it's always about
shots sometimes it's good to be a decoy
and create
offense for others which he's good at he
wasn't even doing that dan
and that's the problem yeah but now it's
mental reg
he didn't attempt field goals in the
fourth quarter
in what five of the seven games he
wasn't they have to put him
down in the in the low post to hide him
because then somebody has to guard him
down there as opposed to on the
perimeter
look uh as much as i love doc rivers
i've been on this show and said he's one
of the the best coaches
he's got to take partial blame of this
because
look we all were reading the stats
coming into game seven we knew that he
hadn't attempted
shots we knew that he hadn't been
aggressive this kind of has to go
the blowback has to go a little bit to
dock as well because doc
knew this but here's the other thing
where does he turn to
is he turning to shake milton is he
turning to thy bull
i mean where do you want him to turn
when you have a
what 23 24 i'm not exactly sure how old
ben simmons is
do you crush his confidence by taking
him out i mean are you gonna grow with
him
so doc has to take a has to look in the
mirror a little bit because
doc left him out there he left him on
the island out there as well
but where does doc turn to but i wonder
if
he can stay in philadelphia
well look someone will open up the piggy
bank for him you know that
right yeah but i i don't it's you know
you're not going to get dollar for
dollar for him it's not like
hey we're going to trade him to portland
to get dame lillard
all right i mean i i don't i don't know
where you can send him and what you
could get in return almost feels like
there's a little addition by subtraction
here reg
um and i think they kind of did that
with their overall number of pick a few
years ago and markelle fultz right
did markelle fultz have a little gifts
and
a hitch in the shot and he was the
overall number one pick
he was supposed to be teamed with ben
simmons it was supposed to be the back
quarter of the future
and it was you know addition by
subtraction again
um so you see what you can get maybe a
couple first-round draft picks
get younger and get lucky in the draft
again
but i i wouldn't close the book on ben
simmons
because he is such a young player i
agree with you that it is mental
at this aspect but this is something
that can be corrected
um it's a shame to see because he's such
a good kid
and he has so much physical talent
he just needs he needs a junction yeah
but here's the thing though reg
there's one thing his form is not good
and
and then the the mental aspect of this i
know they're combined because if all of
a sudden he starts making shots
it's amazing that you feel a lot more
confident about your game
and i don't know do i work on the mental
side of this with ben simmons
and then the physical or does does it
have to be the other way
i think you have to work on the mental
side first um
because the physical side will come
that's just repetition being in the gym
and getting your reps in the mental
approach
i think will take longer because as you
and i know
how philly fans are and how talk radio
is
right as we speak in philadelphia they
are crucifying this young man
and mentally how is he going to come to
grips with that
and he has to get stronger mentally
first
before the physical aspects can can take
place
yeah he's just got to try to survive
until football season starts in
philadelphia that'll
take away the heat from him good luck
with that
good luck um the nets durant was
spectacular
and i don't know james harden's health
status there rich
but james harden in closeout games is i
think one in seven now
he was not good yesterday either and
well he really wasn't good in the three
games he came back for the nets yeah
he was just out there and they needed
another player with kyrie being down
with the ankle injury
and you're right um super human effort
by kevin durant but i put a tweet out
after game five after that unbelievable
game that he had
to bring them back when they were down
double digits against milwaukee
this is a guy that's coming off an
achilles tear i know
and all season long you have rested him
and and he played 48 minutes
if you would have rested him during the
regular season again winning game five
that was the game they needed to get to
go up 3-2 game six
it's a luxury it's not a necessity
i would arrested him and certainly i
would have rested
james harden who played 45 minutes in
game five and gave them five points
the fact that they came back and played
them in game six
everyone killed me yeah you're right no
you go after games
you go no i want to win one game and
i'll sort the rest out later
i'm pushing all my chips in the game
wouldn't you have rather now
in hindsight wouldn't you have rather
had arrested
on three days rest kevin durant
and certainly james harden for game
seven
did you see how how they were just hung
over
in exhaustion both teams but wouldn't
you have loved to have had
a fresh kevin durant and a fresh james
harden
in game seven 40 minutes they played in
game six
and harden was a little bit better than
game five he didn't shoot the ball great
and kd was kd but
the bucks played it smart don't blow
them out
keep it close so they have to play those
minutes
40 minutes both by them in game six and
they come back
and what did kd 53 he played the whole
game and over time
and what 45 for james harden maybe more
in that overtime deciding game seven it
was too much
and on top and having said all that
they were a size
16 shoe on the line from winning that
having me said all that
they still could have won that but i
i'm just saying i needed one game
if i'm the nets i don't care if i'm
gonna take a beating for not
having them play in game six i want them
fresh for game seven
and i'll worry about game one when game
one comes in the conference finals
now if if the nest would have lost game
five
i never would have said that because
that's out of necessity
that he has to play game six but it was
a luxury
that they won i don't need game six i
need game seven
the utah jazz had a great opportunity
missed opportunity and
uh i mean we could look at mike conley
not being in there i mean you win the
first two games reg and then lose four
straight
yeah um donovan mitchell wasn't 100
but still you have home court advantage
and
that the defensive player of the year
rudy gobert got abused
i i i don't was this a successful season
for the jazz
successful regular season you had the
overall best record
uh you've had the defensive player of
the year and rudy gobert you had
the sixth event of the year and jordan
clarkson but doesn't that make it worse
reg
it does and then you know uh
coach schneider was almost coach of the
year so you almost had three of the top
awards on your team
and yet you're up 25 in the second half
on the road and
it's a close-out scenario for you you've
got to close the door and
by any means necessary you've got to get
that game six
back to salt lake city for game seven so
having highlighted all that it's
disappointing if you're a jazz fan
because you can't beat 25 no look i know
comebacks happen i've been a part of
them
and i've on both sides but you've got to
win that game dan you can't be up 25 in
the second half
it's one thing to be up early 25
but in the third quarter with the
firepower they have
you got to win that game talking to
reggie miller hall of famer reg will be
on the call eastern conference finals
that will be
hawks bucks that'll be wednesday at 8 30
eastern more of a coming out party for
trey young or devin booker in your
opinion
i think i said on this show the one
person i was excited to see in these
playoffs
above everyone else was devon booker
real basketball minds like yourself and
mind we know
we understand true players devin booker
is a true player
he just has been on crappy teams his
whole career his whole
young career yeah and we're finally
getting
a chance we we we caught a glimpse of it
in the bubble last season when they went
8-0
and everyone was kind of what was the
nba going to look like
everyone convened in one place so we
caught a glimpse of that even though
they didn't make the playoffs they were
the only team to be undefeated down
there
and then when they added chris paul they
exploded this year
second best record in in the west but
devin booker
i've said all along and people
thought i was crazy because his idol is
kobe bryant and he has taken on that
mentality
that mama mentality by any means
necessary
and i love the dog that's in him and i'm
glad that people are finally seeing it
trey young has been great don't get me
wrong what he's done on the eastern
shore board has been fantastic taking
out the knicks
and the sixers but devin booker
it's it's a i i can't believe he didn't
make
one of the all nba teams it's
i can't even i don't know who's voting
on this
not me not me not me
did the nba have a good season when you
and now let me let me preface this you
know they wanted a short season
very little off season and then a battle
of injuries with marquee players
and now four non-premier teams
remaining in the playoffs did the nba
has the nba had a good year well i
one thing i will say i don't want fans
hitting me on twitter hitting you on
twitter i don't want to hear about
conspiracy theories any anymore i don't
want to hear about refs
or adam silver wanting the big name team
i don't want to hear all that because
they had a shot to have brooklyn and
philly
in the conference finals you've got
steph out
in the playing game you've got lebron
james out in the first round
i don't want to hear all that the best
teams win
what is the success it's time for new
blood we would never know the story of
trae young
of devin booker of donovan mitchell to a
certain extent
if it wasn't for these playoffs so you
need new
lebron james can't play forever chris
paul can't play forever
kevin durant shown why he was the best
player before
the achilles injury and after the
achilles injury
but we need some of these 20 year olds
to show up
and they have so i know the ratings
probably won't be great
but i love new blood i love smaller
markets
being on the biggest stage like
milwaukee wait a minute if we were doing
a pickup game
and and it's lebron and kd
and and you have first pick
well pickup game you need buckets i'm
going with kd
okay if you were going to have
one guy for a season
just one year is is k.d better than
lebron james
uh at this point of his career like
lebron at 36 or lebron at 30. right now
today
are you betting against lebron
i would never bet against lebron
but right now right now
what kd showed me those last three ball
games
we we like to call kawhi leonard the
terminator because
we feel like he's a machine he just does
it over and over
for this dude to play 48 come back with
40
and come back with 53 minutes straight
in that performance those performances
i'm rolling with kevin durant lebron's
like the terminator man
like i i would not bet against him i
wouldn't bet against brady i wouldn't
bet against lebron just wouldn't
look what kd did no no i understand all
of that and kd
is playing better certainly offensively
scoring wise right i just
i wouldn't bet against i don't know i
wouldn't bet against lebron
i just would how about this this is the
best way let's just flip-flop them
on their current teams okay katie was on
the lakers this year versus
phoenix and lebron was on brooklyn
in that closeout situation versus
milwaukee
does it end up the same way
um yes yeah just just flip flop though
katie on the lakers going against
phoenix and lebron on brooklyn
going against milwaukee i'm guessing
durant might have been able to carry
them i think so
scoring was in the first round scoring
lebron would have made the nets
different
and and the backup players different you
know it's one thing to know you're going
to get the ball
as opposed to you know we're just
watching kd
lebron lebron is inclusive k.d is not
inclusive
k.d is just dominating so it would be a
different
nets like i would i would hope that you
know
joe harris would actually show up like
some of the other players would show up
there
and lebron lebron would probably be
demanding that because he would be
inclusive
whereas okay so so what i just laid out
to you
is basically been the was the talk of
the 80s
and up to the early 90s
would you take magic johnson or would
you take michael jordan
because that's basically what we what
you just said one's inclusive
and one is just a dominant right yeah
so would you take magic johnson do you
set everyone else up and
be the winner or would you take one of
the most dominating
scores and mentally tough players
lebron's going to be the the greatest
scorer of all time magic was not a
scorer
like lebron is one of the great scorers
of all time so i get
magic distributor i get a better
defender
i get now not as good a passer and then
i get a far
better scorer so
lebron's lebron's different than magic
you know magic was limited offensively
lebron is not so much
right yes okay all right
all right it depends if i put magic on
the bulls
do they still win six titles
and are you putting mj on the lakers
yeah
with kareem big game james with michael
cooper with byron scott
but how would they have done with jordan
i don't know if they would have enjoyed
it as much as they did with magic
[Laughter]
right i don't think they would have been
the show it would have been show time
it would have been it would have been me
time it would have been my mic
time yeah hey mike dan said that nothing
leonardo said that i'm not afraid i'm
not afraid of jordan
he'd say it too he'd be like yeah it'd
be about me though would they be
as good with mike as opposed to
would the bulls be as good with magic
maybe not six i would say four
maybe not six but four i i think the
lakers would have
too much talent to be denied whereas i
don't as great as magic was
i don't think the bulls would have had
enough scoring around him
i think mike made steve kerr
uh paxton scotty to a certain degree
he made those jud but boost alert he
made those guys
relevant uh what are you what are you
doing today you have no nba
no this is crazy no it's good we need to
take a breather
that was a that was a big weekend it was
that was crazy it was a big weekend to
digest
yeah look i'm all in for new blood i i
know people are probably not happy
but are you bet could you bet against
the clippers right now
because like whenever it feels like
phoenix winning it at all
oh really i have phoenix okay
i have phoenix within it all okay after
being after seeing them up close seeing
how their defense is
now i'll be curious to see conditioning
wise how cp3 is
coming back um but if he hasn't missed
the beat
i still like phoenix to win it all that
includes
the winner of milwaukee atlanta which a
lot of people are going to assume is
milwaukee
i'm still rolling with phoenix all right
reg
great to talk to you bud uh i love i
love these spiritual conversations with
you
you this is why our friendship has
endured because
a lot of times we may agree to disagree
but at the end of the day
i always end up agreeing with you dan
we have that in shooting in common
do we do we
okay let's take a break no no no no no
all i know is reg laughed at me laughed
at me
after a practice in indiana when i was
shooting against mark jackson
and i and reggie wouldn't even stay and
watch
he wouldn't stand walk he laughed at me
and went into the locker room
that still hurts reg it's called i was
trying to build your company no you did
not
you laughed at me you you went not stand
around for this
and then you started laughing you ran
off the floor
i love you yeah well yeah thank you rich
that's reggie miller
be on the call wednesday at 8 30 eastern
tnt the eastern conference finals